we're in problem number seven switch
colors the average of the weights of 14
books is P pounds in terms of P what is
the total weight of the books in pounds
so this is the this comes up all the
time the FCT the average of fourteen
weights of 14 books is P pounds right so
if you had if you had wait 1 plus wait 2
plus able to add all 14 books right
that's just the weights of all the 14
books and I were 2/14 that is equal to P
all right this is just the definition of
average you add up the weights of all
the books divided by the number of books
and you get the average well if you
multiply both sides by 14 you get w1 you
get the sum of all of the weights of the
books right is equal to what p x 14 and
what are they asking in terms of P what
is the total weight of all of the books
well this is the total weight of all the
books right I just take you know the
weight of the first one plus the way to
the second one on keep adding till I get
to the way to the 14th and that is equal
to p times 14 and that is choice e 14 p
choice e next problem problem eight let
me draw problem aight draw the axes
ok
this is x and y and then they draw in a
different color so they have point a
point a which is 2 negative 1 so it's 2
comma negative 1 so this is this is the
point x is equal to 2 free to go down
this is y equal negative 1 and then have
point B point B which is katie then a
point see up here c 2 comma 5 so it's 2
comma this is 5 right point B is the
midpoint of AC so point B is this
midpoint of AC all right so this
distance is same as that distance what
is the value of T so what's its Y value
we know what K is right k is going to
have to be too right so what's the y
value so the y-values essentially just
going to be the average of this Y value
in that y value because it's right in
the middle of the two so what's five so
it's going to be 5 plus minus 1 over 2
which is equal to what that's equal to 4
over 2 which is equal to 2 so this point
right here is going to be 2 comma 2 and
all I did is I took the average of the Y
values the other way you could you could
have taught thought about is what is
this total distance what's the distance
from 5 to negative 1 well that's six so
this distance would be three and what's
5-3 it's too as well but the easiest way
is just to average this Y value and this
Y value and you'll get the Y value for
the midpoint and that is choice C next
problem problem nine so far I didn't
have to draw anything this is pretty
good if k k times 2x plus 3 times X
minus 1 is equal to 0 and they also tell
us that x is greater than 1 what is the
value of what is the value of K so let's
see if for this times this times this to
equal zero at
least one of them has to be equal zero
maybe more maybe more than one maybe all
of them right in order for this term to
be 0 what does X have to equal well for
X to be 0 here X for this term to be 0
sorry X would have to be equal to 1
right how did I get that I said X minus
1 is equal to 0 add 1 to both sides x is
equal to 1 well they told us that x is
greater than 1 so X cannot equal 1 so
this cannot happen that cannot happen
because x is greater than one so we know
that this is not 0 this term is not this
might not equal that's not equal to 0
what has to be what what has to be a
value for x for this two term to be 0 to
X plus 3 equals 0 subtract three from
negative both sides to X is equal to
minus three x is equal to minus three
halves once again they tell us that X
has to be greater than 1 if x is greater
than one we know that X cannot be minus
three-halves because obviously this is
less than 1 so we once again we know
that this term does not equal zero so if
this term doesn't equal 0 this term
doesn't equal zero and but when i
multiply all three of these terms i get
0 this k has to equal zero right this is
non zero this is nonzero if I'm getting
zero when i multiply MK has to be zero
and that's choice B next problem alright
problem number 10 let me see if I've
enough space to do it I should never
just I should just clear it every time
problem 10 if all men in the Williams
family are over 6 feet tall that's not
true of my family of the conne family
but maybe one day if we eat right which
of the following statements must be true
if all of the men in the Williams family
are over 6 feet tall which of the
following statements must be true choice
a no man under 6 foot tall is a member
of the Williams family sure that sounds
good to me choice a no man under six
feet tall is a member of the Williams
family for example i am 5 foot 9 if i
was a member of the williams family then
the first statement could not have been
said that all men and the Williams
family
over six feet tall so that that makes
sense all million family are over six
feet tall so that means that no man
under six foot tall is a member of the
Williams family because if there were
then that you couldn't have said that
all men in the Williams family over six
feet tall that probably required the
most talking and the least writing
online behalf but hopefully that's a
convincing answer problem will Evan let
me know if it wasn't what is the radius
of a circle that has circumference of pi
the radius that okay so we know that
circumference is equal to 2 pi r right
and they're telling us that the
circumference is pi so pi is equal to 2
pi r divide both sides by 2 pi you get
PI over 2 pi is equal to radius divide
the numerator in the denominator by PI
you get 11 so you get one half is equal
to the radius and that is choice B
pretty straightforward a problem 12
problem 12 if Y is directly proportional
to x squared + y equals okay so when I
say directly proportional that means Y
is equal to some constant we don't know
what it is y is equal to some constant
times x squared that's what directly
proportional it means it means it's some
constant times x squared okay why is
directly proportional to x squared + y
is equal to 18 when x is equal to
one-half so y is equal to 18 is equal to
k times when X is 1 half right so when X
is one-half that's all we're saying so
what does this tell us that means that
18 is equal to K times one-fourth
multiply both sides by 4 times 4 you get
48 is equal to K right because this
cancels out and what 48 is the same
thing as one-half so the relationship is
y is equal to one-half x squared and now
what are they asking us what is the
positive value of x when y is equal to 9
halves so they're saying when y equals 9
half let's solve for x and the positive
value 9 halves is equal to
one-half x squared multiply both sides
by 2 this 2 cancels here this 2 cancels
here I was multiplying so you get nine
is equal to x squared so they want the
positive value of x 0 x could be plus x
is equal to plus or minus 3 and they
want the positive value so x is equal to
positive 3 and that's choice D choice d
okay I think let me do the next problem
in the next video I'll see you soon